[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth to work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Rachel Cruz
Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author and co-host of the
smart money Happy Hour podcast ever
popular with George Campbell is my
co-host today also my daughter opened
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
Jennifer is with us Jennifer is in
Indianapolis hi Jennifer welcome to the
Ramsay show
hello
hi what's up
um I have a question so my husband and I
um our own two small businesses we that
we each that's our daytime jobs and
um I'm starting a third one but we're
really struggling with budgeting for
those businesses because they are not
consistent income every month and so
knowing how to budget and our expenses
um
there are there isn't much personal
expenses because we are get debt free
other than our property
um and so I'm just struggling of how to
get started and how to plan
um with the inconsistent income
and is this question more Jennifer for
the businesses how to budget for those
specific small businesses or the money
you're bringing into your household
budget
um really for all of them but specific
more specifically the businesses okay
and are you and your husband are the is
this the only type of work you guys do
are these two businesses that you're
running
um yes and I'm starting a third one that
is
um
[Applause]
I want to transition from my current
role and I have discovered that there
are no resources and so I would like to
fill a need for my current position and
step out of that and work into
um this this other business
okay I'll let you handle the business
side I can do the I can help you with
the household budget though so when you
so Jennifer for you guys you and your
husband y'all need to create if you
haven't already obviously a pretty
detailed budget for your household and
like you said there's not many bills
that have to pay because you guys are
debt free you just have your property
your home that you owe money on
um so so we always talk about
prioritizing so it's giving first and
making sure your four walls are covered
food shelter utility transportation and
then everything else underneath is
prioritized line item Wise by what's
most important and so for some months
for you guys if it's less than what
you're bringing in then you're gonna say
okay we're gonna have to cut you know
the the bottom three line items in the
budget or or lower some of the amounts
throughout the budget so you kind of
have a plan for the lower months and
then when you guys have high months yes
go and enjoy some of that but also keep
some of that aside so on the low months
you can even pull from that fund as well
so it's a little bit of kind of
gymnastics throughout it but having that
in place having a prioritized budget is
really important and then a fund to be
able to say we can pull from some of
this money that's not an emergency fund
but just for those lower months to do
what we need to do so that's kind of on
the household side but I think Dave's a
little bit okay the business that you're
running now what do you make yes I make
a hundred thousand dollars a year for
mine profit
yes and you want to start another
business
why
um so I'm a behavior consultant and
um as I'm an independent contractor and
I have noticed a need and I have
um
uh in the business that I do and so I'm
looking to start something else that I
would hopefully transition out of the
independent Contracting than into this
other
um
the business
okay so you're not in business you're
just an independent contractor
correct uh yes about being in business
you just mean you're 10.99 you don't
operate a business with a with it with
business expenses associated with it you
don't have employees you don't have uh
products you simply work for someone on
contract
yes sir and you're calling that being in
business okay I got you and and you
don't want to do that anymore you want
to do something else
correct and what is it you want to do
um I would like to have a
subscription-based website
doing what
um providing materials for people in
that are currently independent
contractors
to help kind of supplement the work that
they're doing because as an independent
contractor you've realized oh gosh I
wish I had this and a lot of people need
that so I could
yes step in that space okay okay I want
you to just work on that at night
that's what I'm currently this is a sad
thing
yeah that right now is worth zero and
the other's worth 100K so
um you know you're not going to
transition out of that anytime soon
to get your subscription up to 100K and
you get to quit doing your day job uh as
a contractors it's going to be a while
okay so let's just keep with that now
why is your hundred thousand Here
regular
um it's um each month I um turn in
billable hours and so uh depending on
schedules and things like that what's
your worst month what's your lowest
month
um eight grand yeah and and you said you
make a hundred grand
eight grand is a hundred grand
8 300 a month is a hundred thousand
okay so then my higher months can be
upwards of 10
um okay so your your variability is not
that much you could lay out a budget
easily on eight grand and then just do
minor adjustments what's your husband
make
around 160. yeah so you have a 260 000
income to work with and then you can
adjust a little bit off of that so you
don't have a lot of variability a lot of
volatility in your income
not so much
so much in my
husband yeah but you can you can
anticipate that I mean you can look up
and go because we're not doing a budget
for for November right now we're doing a
budget for July right now or August
okay and he know he knows right now what
August is going to look like
um yeah pretty close pretty close yeah
you're look you you don't you guys don't
go to zero you're making a quarter of a
million dollars a year okay you don't go
to zero so you make enough money to run
a budget on twenty thousand bucks a
month 15 20. and the inconsistent yeah
they make the adjustments on the
overages or the underages yeah that and
you know you guys just may be able to
live on way less than that is what's
going to adjust it's just how much you
save per month right exactly it may get
to that point too so yeah you guys are
doing great Jennifer I mean you guys are
making incredible money serious money
and I and I appreciate the you know the
intentionality around the budget because
I think for some people when they when
they are independent contractors or
they're doing freelance work or there is
this inconsistent income a lot of people
just write off a budget and say well I
can't do a budget because I don't have a
consistent income so I think the
question is is really good but you guys
aren't in dire you know you should be
fine even when you're low month you have
a very consistent 15 to 17 000 a month
very consistent that you could easily do
the budget on that part and I think your
side gig Jennifer is awesome I just I
know friends in a field similar to what
you're talking about so anything that
can help them you see a need that's when
businesses and your passion really do
help so I encourage the yeah the work at
nights and weekends of doing that so I
think that's exciting absolutely this
thing started on a nights and Weekend
Deal this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
buying Market but there's a way you can
get an edge Churchill Mortgage works
with you to understand your budget and
your goals and the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge offers you fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus Churchill has bumped up their
seller guarantee to ten thousand dollars
giving your offer the best chance of
being accepted and helping you win in
today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
[Applause]
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today I'm Dave Ramsey your host
this is common sense for your dollars
and cents a concept Congress can't grasp
it's called the Ramsay show thank you
for being with us the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Aaron is with us in Las Vegas hi Erin
how are you
good guys thanks so much for having me I
really appreciate it sure our pleasure
how can we help
well um my wife and I love the show
we've gone through FPU we're in baby
step six right now so we're super
excited about that but a couple months
ago our situation changed
um I'm currently in the process of being
diagnosed with a very rare form of
muscular dystrophy
um and uh so just uh
the reason why I say in the process I've
had a genetics test as a possible match
my doctor is 90 sure and I've done a
biopsy but next week I actually find out
the results of the biopsy and so we've
obviously done the baby steps we're in a
good situation that way but I guess my
question is what insurance and what type
of long-term planning would you suggest
in this and I guess am I too late to get
to the party to get insurance in this
sort of situation now
life insurance
uh yes yes you're too late to the party
yeah okay all right um sorry uh the
uh
and then how you plan for it would be
based on I don't know anything about
muscular dystrophy in this Millennial I
mean I remember sure like the Telethon
when I was a kid or something and that
was that was when the dinosaurs were on
the earth and I don't know what this
prognosis means for you do you
so far
I know it's very rare there's less than
a thousand people in the U.S that have
what I have and
um it's I'm fully functional right now
but it's possible in the next 10 to 15
years I could be uh in a wheelchair and
I could lose
um a breathing function so I'd have to
have a respiratory device Oh Aaron I'm
so sorry oh wow thank you and then that
um following that uh stage it probably
doesn't end well I'm guessing
it's very possible yes it continues to
deteriorate or does it Plateau off with
the breathing device
it it can Plateau but more than likely
it will deteriorate from there how old
are you
I'm 46. okay all right so we're talking
about 60 years old give or take
exactly okay all right I'm sorry man
that's hard to face something like that
I'm
um do you guys have kids
uh no we did not okay how's your wife
uh she's so supportive very very very
awesome yeah she's great well I think
one of the things I'll tell you from
working with families I don't know
anything about the medical world
except that
um they call it practicing medicine for
a reason
they're practicing and so the things in
other words things change and you extra
opinions and continuing to study and
continuing to argue with the uh what's
in front of you is good not in a denial
way but just not accept that that one
guy says okay you're gonna be gone in
six months you go well maybe not maybe
I'm gonna try this and you know so on So
You Know You're Gonna you're gonna
you're gonna become an expert on this
Dad blame it you know to be an advocate
for yourself so I'm going to tell you to
continue to do that and don't just
accept one thing and walk away I don't
think you were going to anyway but
second third fourth and later on eight
opinions just keep working the problem
uh now while you're doing that
uh
there is a
I have perceived in others not myself
I've not experienced this okay so just
like someone calls me up and says I've
got a a stage four uh cancer diagnosis
and they're giving me four months to
live okay that call has come in here
over the years several times or I've
actually sat with people in a room where
they were telling me this stuff and
they're they're uh already have
processed the emotions and now are going
okay what the flip do I do kind of thing
all right so that's why you're calling
so um in in that case what I found is is
that facts are your friends
and so
there is a tremendous piece that comes
from having your spiritual house in
order number one but then number two uh
getting your house in order financially
and you say okay if this unfolds I got
about this many years and we're talking
wheelchair and then I got about this
many years on a breathing device and if
it doesn't stop deteriorating I've got
this many years and so you you okay
based on that I'm going to lay out a
plan and then if I get a different
result I'll change the plan but if you
go ahead and make sure okay I got a will
in place I'm going to investigate and
find out and make sure Dave's right
about life insurance I'm going to
say this is our wealth building plan
we're going to continue to pay off the
house we're going to do this and this
and this and you know you you the more
detail it sounds ridiculous but the more
detail you say given this diagnosis this
is the exact plan
once that detail is in place
it gives you just like a release you
know a sense of Peace but having the
medical be chaotic and the financial
future being chaotic simultaneously is
almost more than some folk can bear
so I'm going to encourage you to do what
continue the journey you started with
this phone call and that is really
detail out exactly what how what is your
version of the baby steps facing this
rare for form of muscular dystrophy
dystrophy uh because it's almost chronic
in that it's not it's not a a one year
or two year diagnosis it's a 15-year or
20-year diagnosis right and so today it
is anyway it may change next week
and it may change for the better next
week so facts are your friends details
in the financial Arena are not you being
cold they're giving your wife peace and
you peace and then you can turn back
around and concentrate on being well
does that make any sense at all
no it it totally does and just hearing
about this I mean we found out in March
and like you said it's it's about you
know emotionally trying to register it
and then trying to figure out what the
facts are yeah and I feel like we're at
that place right now and now I'm going
oh wait I have to plan about the future
now and figure that out which is why
like you said I called yeah and it's a
different it's a different
future than it was in March and
truthfully there may be a
a a a treatment that comes
a year from now you know and then the
the thing changes again because you're
not going to stop studying this you're
living it you know Aaron do you guys
know medical bills
um have they given you guys any
direction like your insurance do you
guys know financially at all what the
costs will be at certain stages of this
and it's because it's so rare rare
they're still I mean it's just being
discovered sort of thing so I I'm in a
research study right now good just put
me in one to hopefully take care of some
of the medical bills but also figure
what this thing out and how it does in
the long term right yeah yeah well I can
tell you this you know continuing a big
old pile of money in your 401k and a
paid for house is still going to help
the situation
so that part didn't really change right
right I mean it it it's if you live with
this at deterioration and disability
um or you don't and you leave her with
the situation either way a big old pile
of money and a paid for house ain't
gonna be bad right that's true so you
know we could keep working four and six
you know the only question is in between
like Rachel's saying do we need to pile
up some cash for interim treatments or
uh treat you know we're gonna fly to
Czechoslovakia because there's a
treatment there that's not covered by
Insurance heck I'm going man Heckle
paying off the house get on an airplane
let's go you know and we'll change
redistribute that cash in a different
way uh out of the budget
and of course you're going to anticipate
your income changing potentially as well
as you go along and so all of that goes
with it but just you know uh
keep adjusting the plan but the more
detail the plan is the more peace she's
going to have you're gonna have and then
you can turn in your energy around to
fighting the disease instead of fighting
the money and that's what people that
are like with a cancer diagnosis are
doing as well so man I'm so sorry and
Aaron we're here for you we're not going
anywhere if you need something you call
anytime we'll and tell your wife to call
if you for some reason aren't able to
get on the phone we'll help any way we
can thanks for calling man I'm sorry
[Music]
thank you
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Greg
and Lindsay are with us hey guys how are
you we're great Dave how are you better
than we deserve where do you live live
in Knoxville Tennessee
well some of us from over there Rachel's
husband Winston's from Bearden there so
when I was born in Marvel so there it is
Marvel that's how you say it that's how
you say it if you're a Yankee it's
Maryville for the rest of you but all
right welcome guys how much debt have
you paid off paid off 117 802. all right
and how long did this take 14 months way
to go guys and your range of income
during that time 162 to 198 000. cool
what do y'all do for a living we are
both CPAs good you're killing it too way
to go so what's the 119 000 what kind of
debt student loans
how long you been out of school
graduation years yes four or five or
four years 2019. yeah good good for you
guys good for you guys so what happened
14 months ago that Lit these two CPAs I
get Smiles on their faces I didn't have
to pay the loans 14 months ago yeah well
actually we I refinanced it was all my
loans
um well our loans but
my loans
um but yeah no it's kind of just started
by
um we went to a trip to South Dakota and
that's where I proposed to her
yep
that's very patriotic yeah and then we
had a 30-hour road trip back and I
started thinking what can we listen to
I'm tired of our playlist and I was like
I should listen to that show that I
watched in college the Dave Ramsey
Network so we listened to it for 30
hours straight and we're like we're
casual in the wedding we're cash flowing
our honeymoon and we're kicking out this
debt yeah so yeah it let us on fire it
was 30 hours straight yeah
by the time you got there by the time
you got home the whole thing was laid
out oh yeah I had the budget in the
spreadsheet already and everything
you drive a minute I want to play with a
spreadsheet yeah
that's cool guys so it did not take uh I
guess both of your trapped in the car
with me gotta help you and uh so well
with us probably I mean this wasn't that
long ago so it would have been Ramsey
personalities yeah
and so uh uh you didn't have to really
talk one another into it both of you
were on board oh yeah we were on board
um yeah both feet in and we talked to
each other and and you know it was hard
at first but just right when we got into
it we were 100 and you know didn't look
back at all everyone kind of thought we
were crazy I think a little bit but yeah
beans and rice it out and um bottom
shelf at the grocery store but you know
it came and went and then right when we
paid it off we were like well what do we
do now it was it was our life for that
so how long have you guys been married
then uh it'll be two years in November
okay okay yeah so we actually we had a
117 000 that we shared as a part of our
journey here because it's what we did
together but I paid off my loans before
that road trip and then we both paid off
cars too before but we consider our true
beans and rice Journey yeah so you were
married right right yeah she made me uh
she made me wait to propose until I paid
off my car
wow I was wondering if um he thought I
was joking or not so like he did do it
so I guess he was really listening yeah
so
great oh my gosh started like The
Newlywed Journey obviously doing this so
for most for your married life you've
just known this life and then you've
paid it off and how does it feel like
are you like looking at each other like
oh my gosh we did it we like actually
did it because what y'all are so like
light as you're talking about it for
some people it's like you can feel the
weight of the sacrifice y'all are like
having fun while doing it it seems so
just yeah I don't know y'all seem so
light with it yeah it really was such a
fun journey I look back on it with so
much emotion it's just it was just such
a Sentimental part of our story and so I
think just being up here we're so happy
to be here and yeah although it was a
lot of hard work but there's a lot of
laughs too I mean what was the hardest
part uh yeah I would go first yeah I
would say the hardest part for me at
least was definitely you know we were
making friends at our church and really
wanted to build relationships with our
friends and you know a lot of things
that they like to do is go out to eat
and stuff like that so we had to say no
and we were really comfortable with
saying no but it didn't get easier you
know as time went on it's just a matter
of explaining to people like this is our
our journey right now this is our
chapter in life and everyone was super
supportive but some some weeks you wake
up and you're like I make all this money
and I feel like I'm not spending it but
we both knew the long long term play and
it was for us so yeah that definitely
was the hardest part I think the hardest
days for me there weren't too often but
the day is just when you're like oh I'm
four or five years out of college at my
CPA license and then we make 200 000 a
year yeah but you're getting on your
knees to get like bottom shelf shampoo
and like the ding cans and everything
you know the cheap food so
um I guess anybody who else might feel
that way I would definitely say off of
say off of social media because
comparison was a big thing so I think
Joy yeah we really unplugged there and
it helped us really just totally stay
plugged in so for sure so even with
friends in the social aspect you know
you yeah they're all like of course the
go-to is like yeah let's go out to
dinner right so did people did y'all
switch it up for other couples listening
they're like gosh we're gonna get on
this journey and they may even have
little kids and they're like oh it going
to be worth it like what were things
that y'all did that you were like oh
yeah we can still have fun and be
newlyweds and it's so exciting and we
don't have to spend a ton I think one of
the biggest things we would invite
people over and have like a movie night
we'd make popcorn make dinner you know
just get creative
um yeah hiking and just being outdoors
so we actually found that being on the
debt free Journey we got more in shape
because we couldn't eat out so much so
it kind of leeched into other areas of
our life which was pretty nice so yeah
well you got the Smokies you're out
there to hike too yeah yeah
very cool you guys all right now two
CPAs you know that the number two career
I'm most likely to become a millionaire
CPAs and you guys you guys got it
squared CPA squared here so uh very you
guys are really on track it's pretty
incredible to be baby steps Millionaires
and what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is when you look
back on it yeah I would say you can't be
50 50 you can't have one foot in one
foot out you've gotta you know look at
your partner your your spouse and just
be all in and that means you're all in
you're not gonna
um you know spend money willy-nilly you
have to really just dedicate yourself to
it and yeah yeah I think the fact that
we're both in it together made a huge
difference I can't imagine not being on
the same page that was a total game
changer for us and then yeah I think
also what Greg said I can't imagine
pulling off what we did if we were
lukewarm about it because it was kind of
it felt almost easy for us because we
knew the answer to every question along
the way it was always no like no
spending don't do this don't do that and
I can't imagine if we were lukewarm and
it was kind of a consideration that'd be
so much a lot of stress right yeah lack
of clarity is stress it's anxiety yeah
way to go you guys I'm so proud of you
who was bragging on you along the way
friends and family I would say friends
and family but each other I mean at the
end of the day that's that's what it
comes down to your partner the person
that's gonna do it alongside with you so
yeah well done you guys we've got the uh
live and give box for you it's the baby
steps Millionaire's book so you can read
about yourself you're getting ready to
be one and uh The Total Money Makeover
book you you've lived it already you can
give it away or whatever same with the
Financial Peace University membership if
you haven't done that as a newlyweds you
probably ought to still do that it's not
only about getting out of debt and um as
CPAs you'll actually find some things
that you might learn too it's not all
about the numbers so well done you guys
we're very proud of you you're amazing
you're Heroes thank you so very very
very cool Greg and Lindsey Knoxville
Tennessee 118
000 paid off in 14 months that's after
they restarted the beans and rice and
they did some stuff before they got
married making
162 to 198. count it down let's hear
three two one
yeah
I love it
man so good what a sharp couple
nobody's gonna be surprised when they're
millionaires by the time they're 30.
it's the one-track mind
it's like there's nothing else
that momentum I couldn't listen to me
for 30 hours in the car
oh my gosh try being your daughter
ha ha ha
[Music]
ha
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for joining us Rachel Cruz Ramsay
personality is my co-host today hey if
you're a new listener and you're trying
to figure out all these uh all this
lingo you hear around here like baby
steps and where you are in the process
and what we think your next best step is
and all that click the get started
button it's a free free process at
ramseysolutions.com we'll help you
figure out where you are and where you
want to go next get started at
ramseysolutions.com uh John's with us in
Canada hi John welcome to the Ramsay
show
hi guys how are you doing better than we
deserve what's up
yeah uh thanks for taking my call
um so my wife and I just got married uh
just over a month ago
um and we're looking at buying a house
within the next couple years good for
you um
thanks thank you
um so our question was uh we have the
option to
um take out up to 35 000 out of uh out
of my retirement
um if you pay that back within the next
15 years and then there's no penalty on
that so you can take up to 35 000
um and use that as a down payment as
part of your down payment for a home
um so we're just wondering if we should
take that money and use it uh or if we
should just leave it leave it where it
is
what's your household income
uh about 140.
and how old are you
uh 25 okay
John do you guys have any other debt any
Consumer Debt
no other debt okay and any cash savings
uh
so we have about uh 170 and then plus
about 30 in the retirement so it's
totaling about 200.
um so we're just wondering if we should
use the 30 in the retirement as well if
we should just stick to the 170
that's great well you guys have good a
great cash well you get 170 000.
well I you know I don't know I'll just
be in there
I was up here and there I guess was it
your was it mostly yours that you're
just saving or did you guys actually got
married that's combined she was saving
too
yeah sure we're both uh we're pretty
good Savers
um and so we've been out of school I
mean you're incredible savers
you're you're like world-class superhero
savers
I mean you're 25 you just got married
and you enter this conversation wanting
to borrow 35 000 or take 35 000 out and
then you come along and drop this bomb
on us that you got 170 Grand laying
there dude you need to leave your
retirement alone put the 170 down or
however many other hundreds of thousands
you can say between now and the time you
buy a house put all of that down and
then go and get the house paid off quick
but let's not unplug the income the the
great growth that you would have on the
35 000. see that's what you're missing
out is the the uh uh the the money that
that 35 000 would have made
that's what you're that's what you're
losing
now because I'm I'm I think I'm
understanding and I don't know I'm not
an expert on Canadian retirement but I
think I'm understanding from you you can
do this without a penalty right
yeah so you take out the money and then
you pay it back with if you pay it back
within 15 years yeah I heard that part
but there's no penalty yeah so so but
what you do lose is all the money you
would have made on the 35 000 as an
investment
yeah I guess we were just thinking if if
that money added to the deposit on a
home would save us
I don't know the same amount of money or
more or less no because your home
mortgage rate is lower than your
investment return
okay so not leave the investment alone
because dude you're super Savers you're
gonna knock it out
you're going to save another 35 000
while we're talking
you guys are amazing so yeah let's let
the Investments be the Investments and
then you guys be the Super Savers with
the down payment and then reach over and
pay that house off and work baby steps
four through six which is retirement
saving fifteen percent and throwing
everything else at the house and you're
going to get this house paid off in no
time yeah well done John well done wow
pretty amazing yeah you're just trying
to get that last little bit of
manipulation going here and there's no
need for it yeah because you are the
secret sauce my man not that little bit
of manipulation Tim Is With Us in
Phoenix hey Tim what's up
Central
for you so I'm on my very early stages
I've read the book once
um working on my second time through I
would say I'm on step 0.5 I'm I'm in the
middle the middle of really putting
together and figuring out what my debt
actually is
um and just kind of planning for how I'm
gonna go about this
the reason I called in was I have a
fairly expensive truck that I bought
last year and I bought it as a business
vehicle using you know a tax write-off
where it's over a certain weight then I
can write off the whole vehicle
now I'm I'm ready to you know go all in
on this but and and get myself you know
like what I guess I would call like a
junker car but something reliable and
try to get you know no payments going
but when I sell this vehicle I'm going
to get hit with all of those
um you know tax write-offs I got last
year as as income this year yep
um and I I don't even know if it's the
right decision to do that plus the
upside downness you get from you know uh
I would say I'm probably six thousand
upside down okay so you oh six thousand
more on the car than it's worth
correct okay and and how much do you owe
on it
uh sixty two thousand okay and what's
your household income
uh I make about 225 a year okay and what
other debts do you have
um so in total uh that's part of what
I've been doing here
in absolute Polo and it's kind of a
scary number especially because of how
it's laid out here I am 666
670.91 in that okay and does that
include a mortgage okay how much of
that's mortgage
960. so you got you got 200 Grand you
got 175 Grand in debt okay
and you make and you make two what
I'd make somewhere around 225 it ranges
I am uh you know mission guy so uh as
long as I do good it stays good but uh
it can change yeah are you single
I'm not I am married how many kids
three kids okay how does she feel about
all this debt
um that is something where I am uh
having a little I mean she's game but I
don't think she's all in yet no you're
you're not him all in you're trying to
figure it out still it's okay we'll get
we'll give her a minute okay yeah yeah I
think the toughest thing for her is how
it affects a kid's lives how yeah
um how it affects what we Define
different things like that yeah
well um we're coming up on the clock so
let me jump in here hard okay
um
I think you can probably keep the truck
and just pay it off
as a part of paying off two hundred
thousand dollars worth of debt but
you're 175 000 worth of debt but you're
gonna have to commit to do that in a
very short period of time
and that's going to mean about two years
worth of hell
for your for your lifestyle your
lifestyle that you've been living has
got to go completely away because we're
going to use almost all of your income
to clear 175 in two years in other words
we're going to put about 80 grand 90
grand out there a year out of your
income on debt right and then do you be
debt free except your house in two years
but there's gonna be no vacations and
eating out during that time which is
going to involve your spouse being on
board so and you've got to get the kids
will be able to get more details and
understanding before you're going to
want to do what I just prescribed so
we'll help you get the two of those
things going you more details in her as
well it's called Financial Peace
University you may have heard us talking
about it's nine lessons and we're going
to give it to you for free as our gift
because I've been young and broke like
you and you are broke sir
oh yeah you make a lot of money but
you're broke and so you guys really need
to clean this up because you have the
potential to be very wealthy in the
future but not living the way you're
living now
so hang on we'll give you a copy or
we'll we'll sign you up for the class
you and your wife go through as our
guest it won't cost you a thing it's
called Financial Peace University the
only thing you have to do is promise the
call screener that you will actually
attend the class if I give it to you for
free
you don't get to go for free unless you
make that promise because you got to go
and you gotta actually do the class and
go watch the lessons with your wife and
the two of you discuss it and then go
change your life you're overdue to do
that
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth to work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author many times over
and co-host of the smart money happy
hour broadcast podcast here on the
Ramsey networks along with George
Campbell she's my co-host today my
daughter as well open phones a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Anthony starts this hour off in Houston
hi Anthony how are you
I'm good how about y'all better than we
deserve what's up
so my wife and I want her to be a
stay-at-home mom once we start having
kids but if we go down to just my income
as it is now we'll be house poor so I'm
in a field that has overtime and my idea
is to just throw money at the principal
and then refinance from our 30-year to a
15-year fixed rate and hopefully bring
our monthly payment down
does that make sense
well you would reduce the principle
enough that going to a 15-year would not
cause your payment to come up and you
can reduce it even more I guess so what
do you owe on the house
uh we just bought it and it's
approximately 174
000 Leo and what do you make and what
does she make
uh I bring in after your tax ties and
benefits approximately four before
overtime her income varies but 800 to a
thousand is ballpark a month
yes yeah a month
you're talking about take on pay
yes sir so she's not working full-time
no sir
so losing her incomes probably really
not going to be a problem
she doesn't make anything huge problems
but it's just the technicality of being
house poor and just losing no it's not
you know the point is you're not going
to be health support if you're a house
poor over 800 bucks you're already house
poor
how much is your payment a month Anthony
with choa it's about
17.50 a month
all right well if we're only on your
income it's a little high but you're not
house poor
oh okay yeah are you are you guys
expecting
just talking about the future well it's
kind of just plain for the future how
old are you
I'm 24 I'm just about to turn 24. what
does she do
uh tutoring and then teaching at a
homeschool type
program and you do not have children now
correct okay
so it's more just a hypothetical we're
just talking about the future what would
we do in that scenario okay all right
yeah so here's here's
and you don't have any other debt except
this
correct good okay do you have any money
saved Anthony
yeah we do have an emergency fund that's
it
roughly 9 000 right now okay well it's
higher but done a good job Anthony
you've done a good job and you're
thinking about it clearly
um so here's what I would do I would
tell her to Triple her income until she
has a baby
she don't make nothing
so whatever this homeschool gig is that
pays nothing is a nice Ministry but she
could go make a bunch of money right now
before she gets pregnant tutoring yeah
let's go let's go make a pile of money
both of you and then you got an extra
big old pile and then if you if you did
throw 50 000 say at this house and then
refide it yeah you would be able to do
what you talked about and that would be
an awesome plan
okay but the absolute but but the the
good news is is you're not really
dependent on her income to uh survive
and prosper yeah you can make it if you
if she wants to be if you guys want to
choose for her to be a home mom
stay-at-home mom I think you can afford
it but the more money you pile up the
more you're going to be able to afford
it no duh Dave right but that's yeah but
but that's y'all gotta you know even if
y'all start soon try Anthony math tells
me within you know you still have close
to a year
uh for her to be working so you guys
could spend you know this next year just
saying okay even if she gets pregnant
she can still work
um and just like he's saying pile up
that money now and Anthony the truth is
too everyone's story is so different
with this you guys may go do this for
three years until you get pregnant right
I mean like you haven't you you don't
know and so uh doing what I can what I
could on the front ends yeah which is
pile up a bunch of money to be able to
to put to the principal I think
cash stacking business both of you you
picking up OT and her changing her uh
because 800 bucks man she didn't make
anything and she's got the ability to
make a lot more than that and I would I
would say let's reset that with the goal
of okay we're going to pay a price now
which ensures that we'll be able to
afford for to to live this this desire
to stay at home and so yeah you're
paying a price to win live like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else that's it so you guys
are really doing well by the way I want
to say it again I said it once
I mean you're 24 25 years old and you
got your crap together way more than
most people
and you're actually thinking which is
way more than most people do
Sean is in Los Angeles hey Sean welcome
to the Ramsey Show
Steven Rachel I feel so blessed to talk
to you guys today thank you so much you
too what's up
um so I have a little twofold question
here and so it's about navigating baby
steps three being four so
um you'll probably need some facts I was
going to spit them out real quick I'm 34
years old and I'm a full-time
um pastor at a church I just completed
baby step three and I'm super super
excited
um single never married and I don't have
kids and I'm thinking I'll make roughly
around 65 to 70 000 this year
um I currently rent a room and a house
so I don't own property but as I enter
baby steps 3B 4 5 and 6. my first
question about baby step four is as I
receive my money and I get paid in Gross
amounts I'm currently just setting that
amount for my taxes in a separate
savings account this will be my first
year doing the quarterly estimate so how
do I plan for exactly what that 15 will
be throwing into retirement of my take
home I've heard take home pay on the
show no it's not fifteen percent of take
home it's 15 of gross
but if you want to not be doing anything
because you're saving 100 of it to 3B
that's okay with what we teach too
okay
um now how would I calculate that 15 of
my take home 15 or 70 degrees
okay that's true that's that makes it
easy then and then when I approach baby
step 3B you know of course living in
California
um when it comes to saving for a house
where would I uh you know how do I
realistically get ready for that when
you know the the housing prices are so
far out there and I'm making you know
what I make now gonna be very difficult
it's very difficult to buy a house in
Los Angeles California making 60 Grand
70 grand very hard
can it be done yeah but I mean it's it's
one of the most expensive real estate
markets in the world
[Music]
I mean La Manhattan Tokyo London these
are this is the four big dogs Paris you
know I mean this is it and so in terms
of expense San Francisco's right there
with it too
um you know so I mean it's gonna be hard
but you can do it you're probably gonna
end up making some other choices like
living further out in order to do home
ownership with that kind of income and I
wouldn't pause baby step four to save up
for a house in La 1965 I would be
putting some to retirement Sean so I
would because it doesn't take a while
it's gonna be a while
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
whether one
their wash and guarantee and
and see why blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us if you like this show
we could use some help
share it
leave a five-star review
subscribe follow
all of those little actions sound like
they're not much but they make a big
difference in how YouTube or Spotify
or apple
or radio ratings all work
it's a big deal and we know a bunch of
you are sharing the show and telling
people about it thank you because
there's a ton all our ratings and
indicators all our statistics tell us
there's a whole bunch of new people this
year so thank you and it had to come
from you because we don't spend uh 300
million dollars on Advertising for the
show and we don't own any football
stadiums like sofa or somebody like that
excuse me gotta got this allergies are
bad all right and Leslie is in Lynchburg
hey Leslie what's up
hi uh Mr Ramsey and Rachel thanks so
much for taking my call today sure
um I I am 43 I'm single and my income is
around 53 000 a year I work in the
social work field
um I currently have a hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt that I'm
going to be tackling
um
the reality of it is for me it's going
to take like if I'm throwing everything
at it it's going to take me between five
and six years on my income
and um is that really prudent like my
employer currently matches my 401k at
six percent is it really prudent for me
to miss that six percent given my age
and you know my circumstances yes
yes it's the only way to do it because
here's what's going to happen the more
you fret about
the retirement not getting funded the
more you're going to sacrifice and the
more you're going to take extra jobs and
the more you're gonna live on beans and
rice and you're going to do it in three
and a half or four years instead of five
okay because part of your issue is you
do need to do something to get your
income up while you work on this
see if you if you had a fabulous side
Hustle
and I don't know it may even be
something in the social work field I
don't know what that is necessarily but
if you can pick up some
um some private case work or something
and add twenty thousand and it's an
uncomfortable number of hours that
you're working
um but 20 000 added to this equation a
year would cut the whole deal in half it
cut it from five years to two and a half
years
and that's how I want you thinking and
the fact that you're frustrated about
not putting money into the retirement
which you should be because I agree with
you it's scary and it's uh and it's bad
to be missing out on the match and it
would drive me a little crazy and but
that's one of the reasons we use that
process we use that tension in the air
to cause you to get deeper and deeper
and deeper and more and more and more on
your sacrifice more and more and more
intense Rachel yeah and it's just and I
think honestly like just just knowing
say you were still funding retirement
you would see that six percent whatever
that match is that you go up to that is
money that could have been paying
towards the debt so I think even mapping
that out to say okay what if I pause
retirement how much faster would I get
out of debt if I had a great side hustle
and all of it like map up the plans
because I think there's you'll see the
light at the end of the tunnel and I
don't think pausing for three to four
years is going to be detrimental to you
I know even at your age at 43 it's not I
mean if you're 65 and we were talking
about this that's more of the like even
more scary is you just feel the weight
of it more but you're still young you're
good do you have any money in retirement
right now
yeah it's uh about 20. okay okay so yeah
how long have you had this debt
okay
so I rushed my case
this that's been laying around
languishing for five years already
yeah and um but and what moves the
needle on the debt is you getting
unbelievably angry
at the dead and visceral about it
um you know you know like when you're
dealing with someone in your world in
the Social Work World when they need to
have a huge life transformation because
the way they're behaving is not working
they have to change then they need to do
that with a level of intensity life
transformation doesn't happen
um
gradually or with ease it's not an
intellectual thing it's a primal thing
you know what I'm saying in your world
You observe that the people that that
get better in their social interactions
whether it's with their family or
wherever you're doing that they get they
get really sick and tired of being sick
and tired they're growling they're
howling at the moon it's very ah right
and yes that has not happened yet for
you on this hundred thousand that's why
it's still sitting there and so that's
what I'm kind of prescribing is this
deep guttural almost uh thing where I'm
just like I've had it I'm sick and tired
of this
you know that kind of thing you get that
thing going down inside you get that
version of Leslie going yeah and I think
most obviously that that the way your
life is looked for five years five to
six years with this debt it's going to
have to look different in the future in
order to clean it up because if you keep
doing what you've been doing you're
gonna keep getting what you've been
getting so I think just kind of that pep
talk in the mirror of like all right
it's it's summer of 23 until summer of
25 like it's I'm I'm doing this and and
and time goes quick too that's the other
thing yes the sacrifice is not fun
working long hours you're gonna be
exhausted but you're gonna look up and
be like okay it's been two years like I
did it and the more you sacrifice Leslie
your time by working the more again
probably not a ton of sacrifice in your
lifestyle because you know it's not like
you're making a hundred grand so there's
going to be some tension though and
that's okay because it's for a period of
time and I'm telling you the more
intense you get with it the more Focus
you get like what he's saying that's
when you're going to see this progress
so you're doing incredible work just in
the world so that like that amount and I
want I want freedom for you Leslie like
I want you to have a level where you're
not stressed and this level of control
over your income in your life so you
deserve it you do yeah be rewarded for
all your hard work yeah you work too
hard to be broke and you're doing too
much good to be broke and just keep
telling yourself that it's a it's a it's
a thing you got to get into here
and you know the this whole guys out
there this whole student loan thing
um there's a lot of different
dynamics that are happening not only
with the Biden Administration for giving
and then the Trump Administration
pausing and the Biden Administration for
giving and then not forgiving and then
the Supreme Court and then Biden comes
out and announces a new plan which is a
worst version worst version of the plan
that was already in place before he even
got in office
um and it's now now you can stand up for
25 years and hope for forgiveness this
is the new plan they announced last week
which is just so ridiculously laughable
then it just sounds like the federal
government the idiocy that comes out of
Washington DC it's just idiocy and
that's not a political party thing
there's just a there's a ton of idiocy
coming out of there and it's got D's and
ours on it and so you know you just got
you guys got to look up and not depend
on that that's one of the variables
going on but the other variable if you
just set aside all of the Washington
garbage and the hyperbole in the
rhetoric and all that and you just say
gosh I make 40
make fifty three thousand dollars a year
I'm 43 years old I got a hundred
thousand
if you just lay those three numbers out
there in her life
I know exactly what that means it feels
that is that that hundred thousand is a
big mountain and it feels like it can't
be climbed
it feels like or if it is it's gonna
take so long
and and that sensor that that little
tinge of hopelessness that is normal
when you have numbers that were the num
where the number is so big that it
steals a little bit of your hope and you
think the only light at the end of the
tunnel is an oncoming train
that keeps you from getting started
and sometimes the most important thing
is to start and then the next most
important things turn up the heat you
know and then the next most important
things turn it up again we talk about
how health and money are parallels that
are following this doctor guy on
Instagram and he posted today he said uh
90 for 95 of you not being where you
want to be healthy wise is your mind wow
your body will follow yeah and there
it's that decision making you guys it's
so powerful it's so powerful and money
and I was watching the Arnold
Schwarzenegger uh documentary that's
good and first the first one was a
bodybuilder he talked about the exact
same thing your mind and your body will
follow yeah this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the debt
free stage Amanda is with us hi Amanda
how are you I'm good how are you guys
better than we deserve where do you live
uh Wentzville Missouri yeah which is
near St Louis oh okay outside St Louis
cool well welcome to Nashville thank you
good to have you and all the way down
here to do a debt free scream how much
you paid off uh 36 850 way to go how
long did that take about 27 months good
for you and your range of income during
that time I was at about 49 to 65. good
for you cool what do you do for a living
I'm a licensed veterinary technician oh
yeah good that's fun yeah and uh what
kind of debt was the 37 000. I mean all
kinds of things a bed a car personal
loans medical debt
um an air conditioner unit is kind of
what started everything
um you living life pretty much and it's
all on the card yeah wow yeah you were
normal basically yeah so what happened
uh 27 months ago two and a half years
ago well two years prior to that I got a
divorce in 2018
um after being married for 20 years
um amicable um so that all went fine but
two years after that you know I had
refinanced the house and all those kinds
of things and you know just your basic
house stuff the air conditioner unit
um failed and I needed a new one and I
was already had other debt obviously and
I had to put it on credit and got
guilt-tripped a little bit from some
family members of like oh well why'd you
do that and are they with you today no
no it's not them
so I mean that's somebody that loves you
that guilt trip that okay yeah so it
just kind of got the ball rolling of
just being fed up basically of just not
being able to make ends meet not having
an emergency fund not having any of
those things so
you know the stress of that and I was on
a single income so it was just me I
didn't didn't have the ability to rely
on a second income so I had to figure
out what I needed to do for me good for
you that's amazing so during this time
what would you say were the things that
were the most helpful
so people listening right now that were
like hey my numbers are matching up with
hers what I wonder what are the things
she did that she saw a lot of progress I
mean really was my brother-in-law got me
kind of started on the night of the air
conditioner purchase
um he's I was all upset about you know
the family being upset of me doing that
so
um he asked me to come over they lived
like two minutes across the way and I
went over and he started talking to me
about budgeting and
um talked about your Total Money
Makeover book and is like I'm gonna get
you this book I want you to read it he
showed me how he did his Budget on Excel
I kind of went from there so shout out
to Greg
um but I read the book within probably
about a week and it just was common
sense I mean it was just very simple to
follow and easy steps to
maneuver through so I just I was already
halfway to the emergency fund pretty
much so it took me about two months to
save that and then I
um just started tackling just smallest
to largest just as you guys say and you
know little wins basically chipping away
chipping away chipping away 27 months
that's a lot yeah you would like 49 000
you pay I mean that that's something
that was that was my lowest pay because
that was right at the start of the pin
you know like we were kind of in the
midst of the pandemic and um our hours
I'm in oncology
um technician so I do chemo for animals
so we had to be segregated from the rest
of the hospital and they had to cut our
hours quite a bit so I mean we lost
probably eight hours of paycheck which
you know doesn't sound like a lot but
yeah it's a lot so we we lost a little
bit of money but thankfully with my job
they give amazing bonuses they offer
double time time and a half they want
people to like work there yes and so
that's mostly what you did the size that
that was the biggest part of it minus
just all the coveted bonuses from them
and obviously the government bonuses I
put every single penny of anything extra
went right to it I didn't spend it on
anything extra or you know lavish in the
government's handout I just did I was
just like yeah first of all I'm just
gonna pay off all the debts so then um
yeah I mean I just worked through it
that way and then uh I pet sat for some
co-workers um throughout that time I
didn't even incorporate that probably in
there that much but a portion of it was
pet sitting for co-workers and whatnot
good for you yeah yeah that's amazing
yeah what was the One debt that you paid
off that you were like that feels the
best that you're like probably the
personal loan yeah yeah yeah so when um
this is interesting I'm just watching
you and listening to your body I'm
watching your body language and
listening to you
I I get the sense that that when stuff
comes at you you just lean into it that
that's your nature yeah
um and there wasn't like this Panic
moment it's like this just sucks and I'm
tired of it yeah I just needed a plan
and that was basically what I needed I
needed somebody to point me in a
direction and I mean I'm great at
following directions so it just kind of
fell in sync came on yeah okay so there
wasn't a there wasn't really a freak out
moment it was more of a just like a
disgust moment and game on okay yeah
okay all right because I mean we all
react differently to these kinds of
things when crap comes at us like this
you know yeah you just kind of get in
panic mode where you're like oh man I
gotta come up with this amount to add to
what I'm already paying in other debts
and you know and then just to pay off
the car and like all those things like
you like you say oh everyone thinks so
you got to live with a car payment but
you don't I mean you don't have to live
with any of it it's all personal choice
of what you decide to spend your money
on yeah and I'm a spender like Rachel
yeah girl I feel you I knew I liked you
so what uh what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
um sticking to a plan
um saying no to all the co-workers who
eat out lunch every single day I bring
my lunch every day to this date I might
eat out maybe once every couple months
if that but I just can't stand the fees
these days
um I don't know not not listening to the
masses of everybody trying to put their
input in like you always say they don't
really get a say in what I choose to do
I heard a guy say yesterday don't follow
the masses because the M might be silent
[Laughter]
stuff Amanda proud of you we got the uh
live and give box for you the baby steps
millionaires book because that's the
next chapter in your story you are on
your way you have a whole different
vision for things than you did and hey
way to do it to just as I think as a
single woman you just decided I mean I
just think I just always commend people
that just you did it on your own you
know and that's something to be really
proud of Amen really proud of you are a
hero for sure thank you we're proud of
you it's awesome yeah Total Money
Makeover book as well uh which you got
the whole thing started for you you'll
be able to give it away when somebody
comes across the street with an air
conditioner bill yeah and um you know in
the uh and the Financial Peace
University membership if you haven't
done that yet do it because that'll help
you that'll help you get in gear on the
uh moving on to the next step to the
wealth I mean just getting free is one
thing but getting free so that you can
be generous and become wealthy that's
the whole deal I'm proud of you well
done Amanda all right who was it came to
cheer you on over here I got my dad my
boyfriend Mike and my my sister all
right well they're all
they are Camp Amanda without a doubt uh
good stuff good stuff all right Amanda
from St Louis 37
000 paid off as a veterinarian Tech 27
months it took making 49 to 65 000 all
by herself count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one I'm dead
free
yeah that's how you do it ladies and
gentlemen from St Louis I'm just saying
wow very cool
very cool I mean there is an advantage
to doing this on your own because you
don't have to talk anybody into it but
the disadvantage is you're doing it on
your own that's right right it's it's
the it's the double-edged sword either
situation but
it's something about which it sounds
like she had such great Community around
her but part of that is not being lonely
in the process because I think it can be
isolating if you're like I'm the am I
crazy you kind of start to feel like am
I the only one you know in this and so
when you have people around you to cheer
you on it is but there's I think even
that much more of a like
a good Pride a healthy Pride like I did
that like I did that so I think it's
awesome a lot that's a lot it's a it's a
big story she's walked through the past
few years and she's chosen to just
absolutely own it and it's incredible
yeah absolutely she happened to it it
didn't happen to her that's right I like
it I like it that's how Victor not a
victim this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Audrey's in Lansing
Michigan hey Audrey what's up
sure how can we help
husband and I are facing a little bit of
like a moral dilemma we're just kind of
looking for an outside opinion on it
um so we we work at the same place right
now it's
um a family business in the sense that a
lot of my family works there most of the
people who work there I'm related to
um we make a low income there right now
um and it's it's not what either of us
want to be doing long term I really want
to go to college and he wants to be a
chef
um but if we leave them we're leaving
them in a really bad position
um our business that didn't do well last
year so we're
just wanting to make sure that we're not
being selfish
um or just just trying to navigate
what's the right thing to do okay does
your family or his family own the
business
uh no my um my uncle is the manager of
Pittsburgh business the business as a
whole my family does not own okay
that that would relieve a lot of
moral dilemma
um I'm not sure there's a moral dilemma
anyway but anyway it would relieve a lot
of the relational pressure
um it's not you're not harming your
family
uh only the company needs your help but
they don't but they can't afford you
anymore
yeah we we make enough to where they
never could have afforded you because
you make a low income
yeah we we we can pay our bills you told
me you wanted to leave because you had a
low income now don't back out on it
yeah
that's what you said I didn't say it
yes sir okay
how old are you guys Audrey
uh we're both 22. what do you make
um a little under 4 000 a month
each combined
combined I I can only work two days a
week um I have a one-year-old so I'm at
home with him most of the time
okay so they're going to lose a
part-time employee
that they hardly pay anything
and they're going to lose an employee
that's 22 years old
yes sir I think they'll be okay
okay
where are you feeling pressure Audrey
who is someone have there been
conversations or you guys are just
reading the story and thinking oh gosh
if we leave or is there is there outside
pressure is there anyone else in the
family that's like no Audrey you can't
you can't do this move um
not really in that sense uh it's just a
lot of people have left recently even
though like it's such an amazing
business environment and everyone's
awesome it's just a lot of people have
left and we don't want to be another
couple people to I guess her everybody
says once people leave everyone else has
had to pick up so much of the slack
um we just so I I hear you I hear you
and I and I commend your you know
selflessness your your heart around this
I think it's a very
gracious
um mindset that you're in but also
Audrey you and your husband need to go
live your own lives if this is the
decision that you guys want to make for
you all you can't you can't be dependent
upon how everyone else is going to feel
in your life there's a point you have to
give that you're and that's not being
unkind the way you leave is is could be
unkind right so you can be gracious in
how you do that but the decisions you
make in your life yeah they have to be
for you lots of notice with a smile with
gratitude for the time I've been here
and um but I want to give you plenty of
now to show you because I know we've
lost some other folks I don't want to
leave you guys an alert so we're going
to give you a lot of notice
um maybe a month notice instead of two
weeks or instead of two minutes okay so
that's a lot of class and and the second
things I got a lot of class on is just
gratitude
uh thank you so much for what you meant
to us early in our lives here and then
can I have permission to be mean for a
second
yes sir okay if this business is
dependent upon a 22 year old and a
part-time 22 year old to make it it's
not gonna make it
if you're the last thing that when you
step out causes this thing to fold up
like a tent it wasn't going to make it
anyway honey
yeah I I think I think they will yeah I
think we're probably just yeah y'all are
being very sensitive yeah you're just
being very sensitive yeah I just what
I'm trying to say there is not to put
you guys down but I'm trying to say that
you're if if it comes down to uh one or
two people inside of Ramsey being here
or not being here whether Ramsay folds
up tent or whether Ramsay doesn't make
it then we were probably gonna make it
anyway
yeah and that's so you it just is and
they've been through a hard season I
hear you saying that a lot of people
have left so yeah they're feeling more
and more pressure so you're more and
more insensitive to that which is and
you've heard the family all talks about
the ones that left and you don't want to
be one of those but you're getting ready
to be and that's okay
and uh yeah you can't uh you can't be
responsible for how someone else decides
to
um interpret all of this you guys are
you're not being mean you're not being
unethical you're not being unkind you're
not being greedy you're not being any of
those things and and and anybody that
tries to put that on you guys is not
telling the truth okay so I would go in
with you and your husband sit down with
your uncle who's the manager and say hey
we're going to move on how can we do
that in a way that is the kindest to you
and to this place because we're so
grateful for this place
I mean do you want us to give you a
month's notice do you want us to leave
this minute
um what is the best thing for you all
because we're going to move on because
we can't making money here this place is
struggling and you know we have other
dreams or 22. my husband has a dream
yeah I'm being a chef I have a dream of
being this and we're gonna go live that
dream and how can we do that that is the
kindest to you into this place and we
want to be classy help us to do that
teach us we're young uh you're you're
the old wise manager teach us how we can
be good uh how we can leave with class
because we're leaving
and if he tries to pull something that
causes you to stay just smile and say no
we're not going to be able to stay how
can we leave in a way that's going to be
the most helpful yep and you may have to
repeat yourself a couple of times it
sounds like
how does that feel Audrey
[Music]
just knowing that it's not wrong I I
know that my uncle is one of the most
amazing people tell him that he'll be
very good at it yeah just tell him that
just say you know we admire you so much
the last thing we want to do is hurt you
we think you're one of the most amazing
people but that doesn't change our
decision yep I mean I've had people
leave here and they go you know Dave you
changed my life and you know my family's
changed because I got to work at Ramsey
and I will always be friends and thank
you you're an amazing leader and tell me
things like that as they're leaving and
then I've had other people give me the
bird and walk out the door you know so I
mean it's
um you know but you can you can you can
decide who you are it doesn't change who
I am right doesn't change who your uncle
is it you just said decide who you are
and that that's what we're telling you
to do yeah and I think it's a and I
think it's a healthy exercise for you
and your husband you guys are you're
feeling this nudge to go do something
else and it takes courage and maybe I
mean at 22 I know you know you have a
little one and all that but it you're
continuing to grow into yourself Audrey
and into who you guys are as a family
you and your husband I mean it's you're
making these adult-like steps and you're
facing adult-like conflict and decisions
and it's scary and it's uncomfortable so
um but it's you're good you're not
morally doing anything wrong so here I
say that what I want you to you started
this conversation stuck and I want you
to leave this conversation not being
stuck
that that's our goal okay you're not
wave goodbye with a smile and do it now
not in a year
thanks for calling in hun open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money
you know Rachel it's disturbing to me
like when we get kicked off a radio
station sometimes because they change
the format to rock and roll or whatever
oh yeah that in like three weeks no one
in that City cares
it turns out that no it turns out that I
mean when you leave people get over it
oh I hear you people get over it you
know ah yes people get over it they they
they manage they manage their lives
without you they're gonna be fine this
is the Ramsay show
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth
to work
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author my daughter
co-host of the smart money Happy Hour
podcast downloads once a week with
George Campbell make sure you check that
out it's a lot of fun she's my co-host
today open phones here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
Charlotte is in Lexington Kentucky hey
Charlotte how are you
hello how are you better than we deserve
what's up
friend
friend behind on
all bills each month you don't
sounds like you got a mess kiddo what's
going on
um yeah I do um I'm 36 single two kids
um I've been working two jobs for almost
five years now and I just cannot get
caught up to stay current on all my
bills let alone start emergency funds
hear you
so what do you make
um what I bring foam each month between
both jobs is 3 200.
but my my debt if I make the minimum
payments each month is 1900
so that leaves me about 100 how much is
your rent
um so I have a mortgage and it's 560 a
month okay that's good news
and um are you getting child support
um yes but not consistent enough to rely
on why
um he just chooses to pay it when it's
convenient to him
well the courts in Kentucky will help
him with his discipline you know that
you've started good okay
um that didn't fix the problem but it
just fixes my aggravation at him and and
I'm just joining you in that
um how old are your babies
I'm 15 and 11 for 12 15 and 12. Lord so
they ate a lot
especially during the summer yeah so
what kind of debts have you got
um car payment how much do you owe on
the car
sixteen thousand okay and um and what
else
um student loans that are about 16 000
when you add them all up
um I have
I've lived life and went on a cruise in
April and so I'm paying on my I'm HDO on
the cruise
uh sixteen hundred okay
okay what else
I've got two like a firm loans one's for
a mattress and one's for tires
how much are those and how much are
those
um
oh and my
Tire
the tires are about 700 and then the
mattress like 200 on
okay
all right and then I've got uh my braces
that that I owe about 3 200 on
and then medical bills that I probably
owe about
um
probably about six thousand dollars if I
had a lot how long you been single you
said
um it's about 10 years
what do you do for your jobs Charlotte
um I am a quality manager and I've
actually had a conduit and I've been
there 18 years and then on my server at
Cracker Barrel and I've been there
almost five years
all right um
let me give you a couple of observations
I've been doing this a long time so I've
sat with people in your situation a lot
okay
um
you've been
um living on nothing right on the edge
scared
for a long time
and that has caused you to give yourself
permission
to do some stupid things that have made
it worse
okay
yes like a sixteen thousand dollar car
you can't afford because the other old
car was breaking down all the time and
you couldn't handle that extra fear
added with all the fear you already had
so you said I'm going to get at least
one thing in my life that is reliable
because this guy paying child support
certainly isn't
that's 100 True just in October that
happened yeah and um and then you got I
well I'm not gonna get out anyway I
might as well live my life so I'm going
on the cruise oh and then the dadgum
tires go out so we gotta have tires
because you can't roll this sixteen
thousand dollar car without a tire
oh
right and so what happens is we end up
going from crisis to crisis because
we're trapped
and
um so we got to get out of this but it's
going to be radical
are you ready
um I'm ready
we're gonna go with you Ben's not
working yeah I'll hold my hand we're
going to jump off it wasn't an evil
laugh from him
hold my hand we're gonna jump off the
cliff together here we go and the
water's cold and it's deep so we're okay
get ready to jump here we go it's gonna
be different here we go run back here we
go that's what I'm laughing about okay I
will go with you we're going to help you
and I'm gonna put people around you I'm
going to give you a financial coach free
of charge I'm gonna pay for it
because I can't stand how trapped you
are it's driving me crazy okay uh and
then I'm gonna pile a bunch of books on
you that I need you to read all of them
and turn your stupid television off
okay one of them is on Career from
paycheck to purpose I'm gonna give you
two of them from Ken Coleman and I want
you to go to a Ken he's our he's our
career expert because you don't make
nothing
and I want you to go get a job making
twice what you're making now you're
worth a whole lot more than you're
getting paid
okay well I tried to tell my boss that
no he ain't listening you've been there
a long time and so it's time to start
looking and it's time to retool reset
your mind uh comb your hair out and get
ready to go on an interview girl here we
go all right okay because you need to go
make some more money you've been
starving a long time
and um uh so I'm going to send you a
bunch of career books and Ken Coleman is
our career guy I'm gonna send you one on
proximity principle ones from paycheck
to purpose read them both okay we're
going to put you into Financial Peace
University which is our nine week class
and take your 15 year old with you it's
nine lessons you can either do it online
or you can do it local church either one
we're going to pay for all this you
don't call it doesn't cost you a dime I
just want you to go do it all
because my heart's hurting for you okay
okay I get where you are I I know
exactly where you are and how how tired
you are and uh you got a new friend
that's going to help you and Rachel and
me okay and thank you you're probably
gonna sell your car because you can't
afford this car this car payment is the
car payment is what drowning you you got
a great mortgage your mortgage is
awesome your car payment is horrible
it's probably killing you and then you
ain't doing any more stupid stuff like
cruises and you're not eating out you're
not going to reward you you're going to
clean up this dadgum mess and you're
gonna work your butt off like never
before
and it's going to be for a short period
of time and this time we're actually
going to get some traction and move the
needle instead of spinning our Wheels
all the time because you've been
spinning your wheels for a decade so got
this Charlotte you hang on we're gonna
get you with a coach we're gonna get you
the books we're gonna get you into FPU
and you're gonna call us back if you
need some help hang on
foreign
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than thirty
four thousand customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today the
Ramsey Show question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for home services for over 40 years
neighborly has an exclusive network of
trained local service providers backed
by the neighborly Done Right promise so
if it's not done right neighborly will
make it right it's a great company visit
neighborly.com today to learn more all
right today's question comes from Jeremy
in Colorado I'm a big fan of your show
and love the videos I'm married and we
have a one-year-old daughter I've been
renting but I'm contemplating purchasing
a house my gross based salary is 243
thousand dollars take-home pay after
401k and insurance is eleven thousand
dollars a month we are paying 2200 in
rents so my question is how do we know
when we're ready to buy a house and how
much money do I need to to buy I'm
thinking I'm trying to think through the
down payment and the mortgage payments
but I know there are other expenses
during the buying process and monthly
that I'm not thinking through and I want
to be prepared
um great question Jeremy so when it
comes to owning a home and buying a home
we always tell people to be completely
debt free and to have three to six
months of expenses saved in the bank and
then you're gonna move on to what's
called baby step 3B
so what you're going to do Jeremy is
figure out okay we're going to try to
get at least a five percent down payment
ideally more than that 20 would be
incredible because you could avoid PMI
and other types of insurance and these
fees that you're asking about later but
we would recommend at least you know
five ten percent down and your monthly
mortgage payment being no more than 25
of your take-home pay so
it'll be kind of around what you're
paying prefer your rents right now
honestly is what it'll end up being well
no because the your take it says
take-home pay is eleven thousand after
401K in Insurance 25 of your take-home
pay not counting 401K insurance it's
just after tax takes oh after tax that's
true yes you're making 243 000. that's
20 000 bucks a month
so your take-home pays not eleven
thousand you know your take on pay
you're counting 401K Insurance how that
out after taxes is nowhere near eleven
thousand it's probably more like fifteen
and so a fourth of your take-home pay
not counting insurance and taxes with a
properly withheld tax amount all we want
to take out is taxes okay and then 25
percent of that number so you make a lot
of money you're going to be fine uh you
you know you need to decide if you want
to stop your 401k temporarily to be able
to save even more and build that down
payment up but uh that's baby step 3B
it's okay to stop that for a little bit
but that 25 take-home pay formula does
include like HOA fees Insurance all of
that yeah within that principal interest
taxes insurance and HOA okay
um and because that's the cost of owning
the house uh not your electric bill not
your water bill that kind of stuff and
so uh but it's just what we're trying to
do is not have have you be house poor
where your house payment is a huge
percentage of your take-home pay but in
your case you probably can go to a three
to a four thousand dollar house payment
without any trouble uh you're going to
be right in you're still going to be
right in there and um probably four uh
maybe maybe between thirty five hundred
and four but somewhere right in there
and that's on a 15-year fixed rate with
as big a down payment as you can scrape
up before you make the purchase now
we've got a great blog on real estate
how much money do I need to buy a house
and it's in great detail some of the
stuff we just covered at
ramseysolutions.com we will put the link
in the show notes for those of you on
podcast and in the description for those
of you on YouTube and so you'll be able
to pull that link up on and reiterate
what you know am I ready to buy a house
because everyone's running around right
now like a chicken with their head cut
off if you don't know what that is
you'll learn it from your country
grandmother but if everybody's running
around like crazy right now thinking I
gotta buy a house You Gotta Buy house
gotta buy a house gotta buy a house
gotta buy a house if I don't buy a house
if I don't buy okay you know it's always
been that way I've been doing the show
for 30 years there's always been people
with house fever
and they lose their minds and they go
with a big old debt they got big old car
payment they got student loans coming
out their ears and then they go buy a
house and they're broke
and they can't figure out why the
purchase of a home was not a blessing
it's because you bought a house when
you're broke
that's why
you know you shouldn't do that so we are
you know Ramsey you're just too
conservative if not we just are using
some freaking common sense a little bit
of restraint
in a culture where no one ever tells
anyone no for anything
no you shouldn't buy a house you're
broke get yourself where you ain't broke
and then you buy a house and then it
won't be harmful to you it'll be a
blessing it doesn't affect me I don't
care if you do it or not but if you're
asking me how I can be a blessing to you
how I can make your life better we're
here to tell you that and that's what
we've done how much money do I need to
buy a house it's a great blog at
ramseysolutions.com in the show notes or
in the description on YouTube don't miss
that and Jeremy you ought to go read
that too
that'll get him there amen
Tyler's in Eugene Oregon hey Tyler
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hello how are you guys doing today
better than we deserve what's up
um so I have an electric I'm an
electrical contractor and my truck just
busted on a job and the truck's been
giving me problems for a very long time
seems like every two years end up in
five grand into it to do head gaskets or
or whatever and then just did
it again and I'm just wondering if I
should just fix it or bite the bullet
and go get a new truck uh depends on
what kind of bullets you're biting if
you got any money
yeah I got enough to pay for but it
tightens it up
pay for it how expensive a truck are you
gonna buy
I'm looking at 70 grand
okay
because you just spent five
well no this truck keeps giving me
problems I have no other means for I
understand I understand but I'm just
suggesting sir that you're overreacting
maybe you need a new truck but I don't
think you need a seventy thousand dollar
new truck
how much do you make Tyler a year uh
uh after tax is about up it varies but
my last year was like 110. yeah what do
you wire houses or commercial buildings
what
everything but in this area it's just
mostly houses yeah so not a single
person's ever hired you to wire a house
based on the truck you drove
no they all they cared was you showed up
and plugged stuff in where it worked
now the showing up part I'm with you on
brother okay I think your truck's laid
down I think it's time to get rid of it
but you don't need a 70 000 truck that's
construction site bullcrap
let me tell you who the broke people are
on the construction site the people with
no trucks you all know the rich people
are on the construction site the people
with old trucks
so it's still worth it to get a used
truck just yes starts falling apart and
get rid of it exactly because you know
what that seventy thousand dollar
truck's gonna be backed into with the
guys skid steer the first week you own
it
yeah
you've seen it happen I have too I grew
up in construction man
I didn't make this stuff up it's I've
been there I've been standing on the
site when this happened so no get you a
you know the truck you got is probably
worth five grand it's probably a piece
of crap right
I could sell it for 20 still really
decent truck yeah it's still it's like a
collector's type of truck it wasn't
supposed to be a work truck but it
turned into oh okay but a twenty
thousand dollar work truck is an
excellent truck compared to what you
have right now as far as reliability
wouldn't you agree with me
yeah it's just used cars scare me since
this has been Ronnie says you drive it
off a lot it's used
yeah yeah when you've been driving your
new truck for a year that's called used
okay and so you you know maybe maybe 20
not you know let's let's go I'm good
with 30. yeah pay cash you're gonna pay
cash and buy a 30 000 Truck Yeah and
sell your truck for 20.
dad gum man your life's awesome oh we're
out is a net 10.
it's not like a fairly like a family
heirloom what is something what is it
oh it's a Harley Davidson F350
okay no sell it sell it okay yeah I was
just worried another car becoming a
hassle down the road
100 of cars are a hassle
all of them break it's just a matter can
we get something wrong with this idea
that a used car a hundred percent of the
time is going to be awful it's not
there's great reliable used cars trucks
too yeah don't buy a worn out used work
truck buy a good one for 30k that's been
gently used in oh a little old lady
drove it to church on Sunday I mean come
on this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host today open
phones a triple eight eight two five
five two two five David is in Washington
D.C hi David welcome to the Ramsay show
hello there I appreciate you taking my
call from the first time listener and
caller so
um appreciate it sure what's up
so um I am going through
um it looks like a divorce
um we're separated at the moment um and
uh thank you um
so it's it's kind of um filmed it off a
bit but the major thing is is uh the
house you know she kind of left me for
someone so she's living over there but
um and she said at first that you know I
didn't want the house and now she wants
you know the equity of the house so um
with the way things are in the state of
Maryland because I've talked about the
DC but um that they are she can take the
half in the divorce and they do not
allow you to just
um pick the name of the house or
anything like that so what I have to do
is I have to do two options and I have a
third but and I know you might say I
know just from the way I've been
listening to for the last two hours here
that uh I feel like you'll say the third
but hear me out first uh the first
option is to um
go ahead and let her take money out of
my 401k and uh for the difference that
she would get in the house and uh and
then what would have to happen is um she
could take her name off the deed but not
all alone and she'd have to give me like
a certain amount of time say five to
seven years to refinance that round
uh and the reason I say that because
what's left is it would jump my uh three
percent loan up to about eight percent
and
um it would jump me from like a two
thousand dollar payment to like closer
to four four thousand two hundred
something like this yeah um and it's I
don't want to jump to that so
then the second option is
um that she waits and is willing to wait
to an agreement of five or seven years
and then she gets whatever Equity I've
put into the house and improvements and
she would then get half at that time and
um if if she rejects that in the third
and final that's a dumb idea
okay in the third and final one let's
see I don't want you to jump to this one
because sell the house ding ding ding
ding ding ding we have a winner ladies
and gentlemen
David was like no Dave I told you not to
jump to the conclusion
hey David do you have children do you
have children
do you have children
we have two children at um 27 25 and
one's just graduating law school okay so
they don't have anything to do with this
house okay
why are you why are you jonesing to keep
the house
um
I've used it for Ministries
um you know like allowing missions to
come and uh
I post several groupings
um in the house and that's one of the
things my wife never liked um so one of
the things she left for but
um but the big thing um is that uh I I
uh the kids grew up in it and and I
looked in the local area and for the
same price I'm paying for this house I
would basically get in a two-bedroom
apartment kind of where I started at 20.
and uh and and though I would be out of
debt and we told that I was going to be
paid off obviously any credit cards or
anything would be gone with that it just
it doesn't sit well with me on that and
I don't know if that's a pride issue or
if it's just uh why like what you're
describing is not logical okay
um if you got half the equity of the
house and you kept your uh and obvi I
would say half the 401K is hers anyway
isn't it
well we're she's this is after she takes
her half to correct I mean right now we
have about 400 okay
you're basically going to split all the
assets down the middle is what amounts
to you
yeah I mean though she had a long-term
Affair yes but Maryland I understand
your heart's broken and she's wrong I'm
not arguing that uh I'm just talking the
problem with a divorce is it turns a
marriage into a business transaction
right and in the business transaction
the um law and the judge doesn't care
about your feelings I hear them and I
I'm with you on your feelings I got no
issue with that it's not right
um it feels like she should get nothing
to me but I didn't write these laws and
I don't get to do them so my guess is
she's gonna does she have a 401k
uh yeah our assets are around uh two and
2.2 million yeah total
yes
bulk of it yeah and then again is there
debt on the house
uh yeah there's that some debt left 250
000 worth of 6.50 yeah um okay so you're
exaggerating when you say you end up in
a two-bedroom condo
if you're going to walk out of us with
over a million dollars
retirement I know I know and you make
what a year
200 000. yeah you make plenty of money
you're not in a two-bedroom condo David
okay
listen that's just your anger and your
hurt talking
what's my budget but yeah no that's not
your budget I'm doing your budget right
now in my head and I'm better at it than
you are apparently well in Washington DC
no in Washington DC I mean it's talking
about Maryland is what he's talking
about but the uh Baltimore almost and so
it's still not that I mean you're
selling one house you're getting half
the equity out of that you make 200 000
a year whatever the other assets are
going to be split
um and you know you're going to have
some money to buy something else uh I I
so you're what
52 years old 53 years old
57 57 yeah okay
um
and this is a 20 it's a 30-year marriage
yes okay we've been together for 36
years yeah I'm so sorry David so this is
what dude you've just got so much grief
going on that it's really hard to
process this I think you're going to be
glad that the break is clean
if you don't have any interfa have to
have any interface with her except
weddings and funerals in the future
in other words if this house if this
house means you have to keep working
with her
I don't think that's going to be good
for you spiritually and emotionally
you you need a clean break and be going
away and I I wouldn't keep the house I
really would you can keep it if you want
to and you can do option number one is
what you laid out
um but you're trying to be
you you know it I'm just listening to
your story and it feels like you're
grasping at straws trying to hold on to
the past your kids your kids didn't
leave anything in that house they have a
future life they've got degrees
their mom and dad got divorced it kind
of feels like almost the last page David
of that time of life and you were forced
to turn the page because of your wife's
decisions and so it it it is that last
bit of this was my old life I would
think that's how I would probably
process it like
it is and so there's all of that and
with this type of divorce I mean grief
is the word I mean it's it's a death of
what was that relationship that was so
um there's a lot a lot there David but
yeah from just the financial aspect
which is what we do best on the show is
well it's emotional and spiritual I I
but just from the for the facts is a b
and c option one two or three yeah the
third is gonna be best for you David you
and I are close to the same age and I've
had lots of friends go through this
similar stuff and the ones that uh have
constant ties back to a spouse that
every time they have to deal with them
it picks the wound open again and if you
can just leave them alone and let them
go over there and do their thing the
wound can heal but when you have to go
back and you have to negotiate and then
she goes and gets married and gets mad
and decides she's going to sue bring you
back into court and try to force your
refinance
um or you're right up to the line on the
refinance and you're 30 days over so she
wants to drag you into court there's
always there's always this crap going on
odd infant item it just goes on forever
and and there's just a a financial and a
relational and an emotional mental
health benefit to a clean break and you
don't get one in this deal without
selling the house so you can do option
one if you want option two sucks don't
do that for sure but you can do option
one if you want but if I woke up in your
shoes sir I'd get rid of the house it's
just a freaking house
there's a house on every corner in DC up
in there this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
therefore is God's chosen people holy
and dearly loved clothe yourselves with
compassion kindness humility gentleness
and patience
Rick Warren said humility isn't denying
your strengths it's being honest about
your weaknesses Susie's with us in
Minneapolis hi Susie welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi hi what's up
okay this is without going too much in
my past I married when I was 30 years
old and
um didn't really know to look that
finances were such a huge deal I was
always brought up with while watching my
dad and my brothers and everybody
provide very beautifully and I married a
man that I should have looked into his
past but found out you know like that is
in their marriage he has gambling
problem and I went through 15 years of
trying to fix all the stuff he was doing
deceitful under my back and in the
meantime lost the house and and
bankruptcy as our closure and everything
stripped from underneath me painful
thanks so I've been divorced 10 years
and I um
you know in the meantime I was a
stay-at-home mom and I had when I found
all this stuff out I started I I started
a cleaning business and I I got myself
out of this whole mess and I bought a
townhouse and I sold that recently
um it was pretty much paid for and put
it into a house and I modeled that
um
good for you I cut my cars paid for I
have zero zero debt I'm good five now in
10 years I've haven't really dated
um never found a real godly man or
somebody is uninterested and I hear I
signed a man
but I don't get my heart don't want to
get my heart involved but it kind of is
I've went on about seven days with them
but in the meantime I'm kind of hearing
some things that I'm not loving with
finances when I can't the car payments
he's living in a little town house and
so I have to be honest and say you know
tell my past and say you know I'm at an
age that retirement's going to be coming
soon and I just can't get myself
into a situation like I had been in
again
so is he smart I mean he's 55 too he's
got he he's just about his townhouse
worth 250.
um he's got a 30-year mortgage on it
which would mean he's not I I don't
think any of that matters
it doesn't no you you already know that
that you don't agree with what he's
doing you don't know the details don't
matter
what he's doing is scaring you
yeah
that's what I think I heard did I hear
that
well you yeah it's like we don't think
he's got a gambling problem but we think
he's just kind of normal have you have
you mentioned it to him Susie like
you're like yeah
yeah woman I just want a stable
situation to be in if you say that out
loud then that explains it
what I don't want to look like some
money hungry woman but I went through
all this hell for a decade and a half
before and so I've kind of wounded
and in that wound it makes me a little
bit scared when I look over and see any
kind of
debt
makes me scared and it's okay to say
that that doesn't mean you're weird it
actually just means you know who you are
okay good and if you're not attractive
to him based on you having an authentic
open conversation about what has
happened to you in your past and the
views and the values that that has given
you to go forward then you didn't find
your guy
great am I wrong
he's been very old I didn't say he was a
liar
you see though and tell me this
this just thinking out loud for you know
we have a small portion of the U.S
population that follows the Ramsay plan
right so majority of people out there
don't so I would be curious oh it's it's
huge Rachel if you would say
to him like Hey this is the plan that I
do I don't believe in debt like here are
the things that I've done to not just
protect myself but a way to live with
money and you may find Susie possibly
that he's like oh I've never thought I
thought you always had to have a car
payment and not that you're going in to
rescue him but he may have never even
thought of a different way of living
because nothing that you're saying is
outrageous a lot of people do 30 or more
so a lot of people have car loans and
again it's not
um you might be his wake-up call I don't
want you to be a savior wait I don't
want you to like go in and like yes then
not I don't want that mentality at all
for you Susie but just through
conversation if he's a man of character
and a man that's like okay I understand
common sense I totally get Susie while
you're coming at it like this that makes
complete sense and I've never thought
about never having a car payment well
sure if I got 240 000 that you said he'd
put down on a town home he's probably
got money in the bank he could ride off
the car you know pay off the car today
it's like he may just not even think
through does that make sense like he may
not even thought think about this way I
think you misunderstood me the how the
house he bought was 200 the townhouse he
bought was 250 000 and he's got a
30-year mortgage
but we don't know how much money he has
in the bank
no I don't but I don't think a lot I
don't either but you you and I are both
you and I are both guests save Susie's
relationship because I'm excited that
you went on seven dates with them yeah I
want it to work for you Susie yeah I'm
not trying to run him off I'm just
saying I think me too I I think you
don't know enough because you've been
afraid of how you're going to be
perceived when you be you
I want you to be real comfortable with
being you because I've talked to you for
just a few minutes and I really like you
the whole I go I think you need to hear
my whole story and this is why I have to
ask I went through bankruptcy when I was
28 Rachel was a baby well I didn't know
if I was gonna be able to feed her it
scarred me for life I don't borrow money
and if you don't like that about me I'm
okay with that I'm still going to be me
if it was your first date and you're
asking for his tax returns and 401K
status like that would be weird that's
weird you're seven dates in and you guys
are adults this is what you talk I mean
you're not 18. I knew I was good with it
he was fine telling me all of it you
know yeah I'm just saying nothing that
he's doing is completely
absurd do you know what I'm saying like
he's living a quote unquote very normal
way of living but that may not be up to
your standards Susie if he doesn't want
to change then that is that would be
that could be an issue you know 18
conversations from now not the next one
if he's saying I'm going to stay in debt
and I think this is okay I understand
that you don't want to do that because
of where you came from then you got to
decide but today you don't have to make
that decision you just started the
conversation you're okay you're okay
you're not out of line and by the way
Rachel's saying he's not either at this
stage
but now you do need to get lined up
before you put a ring on it right
well yeah I just I always just envision
myself at this age to find somebody that
was established I'm like he is
established
he's not doing drugs he's not gambling
he doesn't beat his children he is
established
he's fine Dave well I mean seriously his
biggest sin is he's got a car payment
this guy's a winner
I mean really think about it Dave Ramsey
just said that well I mean you know yeah
we can get rid of the car payment we
can't get rid of it like a character
okay that's it that's that's the line
well that I know that's huge he has a
decent guy he's a good godly man you
said earlier I'm going with that yeah
and I'm with Rachel but I don't think
this is going to be one conversation I
think it's a gradual thing you just keep
talking about this is who I am and
you're not ready to throw down an
ultimatum today get rid of the car
payment or I'm gone we're not doing that
today it's not but at some point you
guys do need to get a line yes before
you start making it permanent but it's
it's okay seven more dates hello you
know let's just keep the door open keep
talking keep walking and if at some
point he bows up then you'll have to
decide at that point do you know are you
are you willing to engage and you
probably aren't based on hearing you but
I don't think this guy's gonna blow up I
don't hear it I don't hear anything in
here that is so I may be wrong I'd love
to hear back how this uh love story ends
I know Susie update us yeah we're not
we're not very good at matchmaking
around here so if we actually score on
one it'd be nice to hear about yeah that
puts us our
number there's ultimately
to financial peace
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]